former bachelorette Andi Dorfman spills
secrets about the fantasy suite I wanted
to bring a little bit of reality to it
in a new column she wrote for The
Hollywood Reporter the 29 year old
attorney candidly addressed her
perspective on the fantasy suite
insisting there's a bit of a double
standard
she explained quote almost every
bachelor has sex with everyone he goes
into the fantasy suites with and yet we
as a society will go so far as to call a
woman a [ __ ] for having sex with two men
that she's been dating in andis case
things got worse after her season
wrapped when runner-up Nick vile
appeared on after the final rose and
made this confession you were in love
with men it's not sure why why you made
love Andi recalled feeling quote shocked
and unprepared for the slut-shaming
sometimes it's just not okay Andi says
she's not alone she mentions fellow
bachelorettes Kaitlyn Bristowe and Jojo
Fletcher who have faced similar
criticisms quote The Bachelor is never
called a man-whore but when a woman who
is in the same exact situation does it
she gets labeled a [ __ ] and it's all of
a sudden newsworthy